keanu reeves no longer really retired
assassin has killed hundreds of
opponents when they screwed him over or
got in his way there's no stopping baba
yaga here are some of the hardest to
watch most memorably brutal deaths in
the john wick series thus far
this is the death that set john wick off
on his killing spree and any animal
lover can likely relate to such an urge
underneath all the glorious violence and
destruction this franchise is ultimately
an ode to man's best friends dogs and
cars director chad stahlski profess a
love of dogs to up rocks in 2019 saying
his began as a child in a household that
raised irish wolfhounds strahelski's
background inspired him to incorporate
dogs into the john wick films we see
this first with the adorable baby beagle
gifted to wick posthumously by his
recently deceased wife helen her passing
sets the stage for the first film and
knowing her time was near she scheduled
daisy's arrival for when jon would need
her most the puppy acts as an anchor for
the grieving husband giving him a reason
to keep going each day tragically his
tentative grip on becoming whole slips
away when russian thugs break into his
house kill daisy and steal his prized 69
mustang a wedding gift from helen it's
heartbreaking to see the little puppy
die so much so that even the actor
tasked with killing the puppy on set
felt the need to cuddle daisy between
takes he can't blame jon for hunting
down every person affiliated with
killing that innocent puppy and stealing
his car but thankfully in real life the
beagle is alive and well and has been
living with a loving family who have
since renamed him wick
wick committed the ultimate unforgivable
sin in john wick chapter 2 when he
killed santino d'antonio on the neutral
ground of the continental this set every
bounty hunter in the city after wick who
attempted to lose them in chapter 3
parabellum by hiding out in a central
park horse stable in one of his most
creative and brutal moves wick used one
of the horses and the stables as a
weapon to fend off his pursuers placing
the horse between himself and one of the
assassins rick encouraged the horse to
back kick his opponent in the sternum he
then slapped the horse's thigh so it
followed with a double bag kick to the
guy's jaw who instantly dropped like a
sack of potatoes then wick wrapped the
horse's reins around his last living
opponent's neck dragging him from the
stable behind him it's pretty intense
and not a position anyone would ever
want to be in
after escaping from the stable on his
death horse and parabellum wick is
pursued by motorcyclist gangsters
through downtown manhattan in the
process wick executes some amazing trick
riding and manages to vanquish all those
in pursuit the motorcyclists get shot in
the face and crash into other cars
pretty hard amazingly keanu reeves
performed the stunt riding in the scene
skills he originally acquired while
shooting the 2013 action and fantasy
film 47 ronin in order to keep reeves
safe while filming the scene the crew
set up a custom wire harness to act as a
safety net in case he fell or the horse
took off unexpectedly even with the
safety harness reeves had some close
calls which required him to quickly pull
his feet out to the stirrups and quote
make himself small so as to not hit
anything it sounds like reeves job
sometimes is almost as dangerous as that
of john wick in an ironic twist the
russian thurgood orchestrated breaking
into john's house was the son of russian
crime boss vigo tarasov as we learned in
the original film wick and taurus off of
former associates when he was still an
assassin before wick quit his life of
crime and killing to settle down and
marry helen so after vigo learns what
his son has done he warns joseph about
wix's quote focus commitment and sheer
will comparing him to the russian
boogeyman we call him
to give his heedless son an idea of how
dangerous wick is viggo tells joseph
about how he once killed three men in a
bar using only a pencil this story is
later repeated by vigo's brother in
chapter two but stahelski wasn't content
to just let his audience hear about this
mind-boggling feat later in chapter 2
wick would bring the legend to life by
recreating it while escaping assassins
in new york cornered by two men in a
small cafe area and bleeding badly the
scene has wick managing to deflect one
assassin's gunshot or grabbing for a
pencil lying by a service notepad then
he stabs one assailant in the chest with
the writing implement he uses a second
pencil to vanquish the other assassin
and finish off the first the stabs are
in places quite undelightful to watch
eliciting squeamish squeals from many a
viewer it can't help but make you look
at office supplies in a whole new
twisted light
in parabellum john wick adds to the list
of random inanimate objects he uses to
kill people when he executes a fellow
assassin using only a book in the new
york public library you would think a
library would provide a safe haven to
read but even there wit can find no
peace boban yamanovich of the dallas
mavericks plays his towering opponent
ernest he corners wig down one of the
abandoned isles and uses his long limbs
to his advantage to make matters worse
mayanovich's character has a knife and
manages to strike true stabbing wick in
the shoulder after a few deflected shots
then he grabs wick and kicks him down
the aisles while loudly and ironically
whispering for him to be quiet
the tide's turn for wick when he manages
to grab a particularly thick tome and
hits ernest squarely in the crotch
throat and face with it wick follows
with a crushing death blow by plating
the book on a tabletop smashing ernest's
face into the spine he bends his neck
and jaw back in horrific angles
accompanied by a sickening crack
perhaps one of the wildest sequences in
the john wick film takes place in
parabellum while on the run from ninjas
wick makes a stop inside an antique
weapons store to arm himself old west
style his foes follow him inside and
they all begin volleying knives at one
another like nerf darts shattering
countless glass display cases and
mirrors in the process one of the ninjas
gets stabbed in the back by two knives
thrown by his comrade before being
stabbed in the groin and a few other
areas of the body by wick much more
stabbing follows culminating with one of
the last surviving ninjas getting slowly
shanked in the eye which is super
uncomfortable to watch to top it all off
wick finishes off the last ninja by
throwing a tomahawk into a skull from
across the room it may look like chaos
but this sequence was intricately
planned and took a massive amount of
effort to complete stahelski told
polygon the inspiration for the scene
came from the good the bad and the ugly
when the big bad two go into a gun shop
after hours for supplies after starting
with that spark of inspiration stahelski
expanded the scene to include an epic
knife fight akin to what he eloquently
described as a quote snowball fight only
far deadlier
many scenes in the john wick films use a
combination of cgi and practical effects
to create images that would otherwise be
impossible or incredibly dangerous to
perform without digital aid one such
example is an epic motorcycle chase
scene in parabellum when some of zero's
ninjas are chasing wake through brooklyn
the scene gets even spicier when the
ninjas pull out katanas and attempt to
slice and dice wick while they're all
riding around on two wheels wick manages
to turn their sword against them
skewering ninjas like sheesh kebabs who
then crash into each other in an
explosive domino effect despite the
hyper-realism of the scene the riders
hitting the pavement were all edited
into the scene with cgi layered into
shots with real actors a stride
motorcycle sled riggs mounted in front
of green screens the cringe-inducing
scenes go to show how great of a job the
visual effects team performed
burning to death sounds like one of the
most painful ways to face your final
moments even so those are the
consequences for being complicit in the
killing of john wick's dog and theft of
his car this fiery moment of vengeance
takes place in the original film when
wick finally locates joseph tarasov
thanks to his dad vigo sharing the
information with the determined assassin
it seems there's no honor among thieves
even when they're family wic tracks
joseph and his thugs to a safe house in
brooklyn which suddenly becomes no
longer safe and our thugs flee for their
cars in hopes of a quick escape however
wick remotely blows up their cars before
they can flee which explode in
spectacular fashion when did he have
time to plant bombs on multiple cars who
cares they go boom while keanu reeves
walks in slow motion and that's what
matters while trying to make one final
desperate escape rick shoots joseph in
the stomach before shooting him in the
head while he's in the process of
protesting that it was just a dog though
he actually got off easy compared to the
guys who caught fire from the car bombs
and the dog is never just a dog
john may not be able to bring his puppy
daisy back but at least he's able to
reunite with his car chapter 2 opens
with wick infiltrating the chop shop of
abram tarasov uncle and brother to the
late joseph and viggo respectively with
wix 69 mustang in his shop he fears the
buggy men will come for his car and
leave a path of collateral damage in his
wake abram fails an accomplice in on the
gritty details of wick's capabilities
and a serious predicament while tara
sarva's telling his story wick is right
outside working his way into the shop by
quietly taking out abram's guys one at a
time one of those guys is on a smoke
break when wick sneaks up behind him and
as tarasov's voice over plays on
describing wick's focus commitment and
cheer will wick shoves a cigarette down
the man's throat from the rear then
punches him in the gut and while
covering his mouth forces a smoldering
cigarette down the man's throat one can
only imagine how brutally that would
hurt after decades of folks complaining
that hollywood glamorized her smoking
here's one scene that would seem to
drive home another albeit rare danger
associated with nicotine addiction
wick continues his quest to get his car
back with his next most brutal kill
which follows shortly after choking our
brahms thug with his own cigarette the
vengeful assassin sneaks up behind the
next body he crosses past with at the
chop shop only this bad guy has made the
wise decision not to smoke so wig does
what he does best and improvises by
taking him down and choking him with a
wire it seems like a very slow painful
way to die especially compared to how
quickly a lot of the other deaths occur
in the film via more humane manners such
as point-blank gunshots this may seem
like a hard death to swallow but many
follow in john wick's bloody footsteps
at least he gets his car back even if he
does immediately trash it while making
his getaway it just goes to show with
the right level of focus commitment and
sheer will anything is possible even
killing hundreds of people in endlessly
creative and savage ways zahelsky told
the los angeles times in 2019 that he
and his stunt team got bored easily with
repetition so it will be interesting to
see how they keep all the killing
feeling novel in the upcoming films
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one